[Music]
they already got the first parent that
was huge for them trying to get a bigger
gold lead their savings and break ground
they got to ready bag is hiding and
coming Katie
doublelift trying to get away but it's a
double-kill for piglet likely wanting to
make it a triple except he's not even
around Simone Donna left with the
outplay
jumping away dodges the justice punch
and they die together around the side
there's the heroic entrance just to make
sure that this is notified the Kaka win
unless he takes down Wallace and dice
makes it out with a dog passage no one
here the contest perks can try something
he's all beat on the waters is any time
to slay to be able to bounce back around
one here come to me dammit
the double kill
they're gonna try and do as much damage
the way of Cossacks lift here
don't worry
400 miles into the cocoon the follow-up
and Toro
welcome back to the LDL that is not be
possible the plate will tip back in and
chloro has got to have his head
and right now they're going to try
diving this and they will kick the
picked up the kill but that was just
brutal no foul they walk right back out
those for the platform he's gone for the
big flag one bar attack
[Applause]
you know the doctrine there's a good
spirits refuge leopard on trying to
protect him time still coming out Lola
is still looking to going beneath the
PMO bottle swallowing punches over my
grave but ultimate might save Josh he
actually carried the bar get the bottle
through the wall and takes down lower
and what fight is all it took
right this time oh wow
damn that was sick that was awesome
cabana anymore really solved I'm not
gonna get many more Bob's submitting to
defeated by Baron it's very low and
they'll and this fight can be consumed
he's going back in lock step back a bags
that happen ain't you put it away from
that material
mobster down here comes to reading it
once again for a fish wants to add to
four kills already one man stands alive
and he's going to fall the AIDS for
Samsung Galaxy this evening
not even close
like ultimatum blocked out by the Perry
from Cisco we run around in the won't be
- he doesn't need the brook to come up
he doesn't cry hey idiot got it
they kill him at me honey get the way
away - you have to chuckle oh hi ma
let's find out which fiesta wins in
managed against a system down but he's
gotta call you
beyond fanatic used in the fight there's
no feel for him as Khan wants to turn
around and kill ya looks for it actually
does a decent job there on the pink of
the flash oh my god finds a waypoint now
wolf he's in trouble that double count
by Khan also a trade happening in the
middle lane Ian's old first behind enemy
lines new double easy to catch pretty
much flashing for calling and first gets
the solo kill welcome back to lane
Kingdom mid laner versus ad carry part 2
program lunch this again everybody
thought hey this time in fact it's about
throwing up things back the g8 go see a
he's trying to get the damage he gets
one but gets dropped Connie follows up
and Scout chases him back mystic is
doing what he can
zero beats the snare Scout goes in he's
trying to turn her up and mystic is
alive Koro is trying to line up the shot
but he has been he's in the way
Oh water shot tea maker they're trying
to take that hurting if they hold made
of comes in once again as gorilla looks
for lenity with the shock wave attorney
just takes so much punishment or the
first time McMahon face up absolutely
fainted he picks up the mark I'm gonna
have to be the real hero it's been good
has he been amazing he might be able to
kill expensive execute Mike Yaga we're
gonna steal the way the Bourbon is
getting chunk he has to be tempted to
buy time because [ __ ] Haley don't flash
forward with the deal comes out they
turned to walk this thing feels like you
get back into the fight just a hunch on
the Ohio Samba one more shot as Walt
wants the glitter lands
that's misfits pull the trigger once I
beat your top seven tablets great
malahide went so far to just be in
second on the mystic buddy shield
they're able to see him along goes down
in the back VidCon is gonna try to
assassinate it but that is way too deep
stages that is they keep him up so he
goes death and they're going to try to
collapse initiate he goes down to put
that Conde dropping as well the lore is
cutting it out on the back and been
burning for his life and his works like
they drop copy with a big force pulling
prints Wow look at the
triple kill
where the heck is my team and why now
baby they pretended from beyond was
stunning barren can be easy enough and
also they actually go in there looking
for the fight right now the Cataclysm is
shin and she's going for the Nexus he's
trying to break it down Megan's gonna
try to stay at his outfit the rest of
wer falling onto the Nexus W we got it
redemption for 2016 bear and empowered
speed does get them good they're a
little bit quicker and this might be the
last push onto this in entire
temperatures I tried 41 city kids back
from frontline they found Emma senses
gone
young cannot do wrong this game with the
touch now turning at the front side of
the turret
have it are gonna fall as well even
though tapas respawn but Phoenix one in
a 5 B 4 and the gold Leafs don't matter
any more than too many people so many
games Brits like I'll played the Fuhrer
I got 7 kills on her and then she goes
yeah well speaking of kills they would
spit their cats was insane like now it
looks like they're on the chase for pawn
but again you're chasing in Kassadin a
very hard thing to what is that he's
trying to turn it around now but he
can't achieve
oh my god plate plate walk
to have the first if it's newsletter try
to make it down to the damage but some
of the trends that look she's only dead
the turret reset he needs to dive down
towards the bottom members hopes up
means he's gonna end up buying a bit
more time so I'm gonna land there get
the big heal it's gonna be big who's
okay though another policeman shrimping
again heat is precious down this spider
itsy-bitsy the waterspout is gone to
flesh the chase Sunday Watson this is
bunnies the chance to steal
[Applause]
slashes over the wall trying to chase
down levy showers running for his life
he took them caps in the backyard and
all of a sudden is at Dan swanky's go to
the front line and see push the
unkillable demon ruler stays headline
chili in the back find a path for duty
does that have a way out pops dig up
when he has no exit routes to a more
audible kill him now when he gets thrown
away they twitch to their aggro they
knock down wolf instead by v3 and mid
that signals the end of the SKT dynasty
there are no turrets it is five versus
three
do you have what it takes
access the upset is completed the cows
come
[Applause]
champion
what a deserved walk out
the deputy Cheers
thousands of jeering Chinese fans
Samsung Galaxy the only team to ever de
throne SKT at Worlds they do it on the
biggest stage league has ever seen it's
time to make building your champions
easier introducing the score eSports is
new builds calculator which allows you
to plug in items and runes to figure out
which build gives you the best stats the
new builds page also gathers information
on what the top players and your
favorite pros are building so you'll be
able to try them out yourself take
control of your champion and try out the
new feature on the score a sports is
builds website by clicking on the link
in the description below
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button